تراجع حاد وسريع في سعر صرف الليره
التركيه منذ اعلان التشكيله الحكوميه
الجديده قبل ايام ففي يوم واحد فقدت
العمله المحليه سبعه في المئه من قيمتها
وتجاوزت بعدها حاجزه 23 ليره مقابل
الدولار الواحد ليست المره الاولى التي
يتراجع فيها سعر صرف الليره التركيه
امام
هذه المستويات
يتذكر الجميع ما حصل اواخر عام 2021 حيث
قفز سعر الصرف الى اكثر من 18 ليره وتراجع
خلال اسبوع الى 11 ليره وفي مسلسل تذبذب
والهبوط فقدت العمله التركيه منذ بدايه
العام الحالي اكثر من 20% من قيمتها
هبوط اخير سريع يعزوه الخبراء الى دور
البنك المركزي في المرحله التي سبقت
انتخابات مايو الفائت حيث حاول ضبط سوق
الصرف وضخ المزيد من العمله الاجنبيه ومع
انتهاء تلك المرحله بدات الامور بالتغير
[موسيقى]
لتحقيق ذلك عاد محمد شمشك الى وزاره
الخزانه والماليه بعد سنوات هو الذي طالب
بوقف سياسه خفض الفائده ودعم البنك
المركزي من خلال اصلاحات هيكليه
الانضباط المالي واستقرار الاسعار من
اهدافنا الرئيسيه لتحقيق نمو مرتفع
ومستدام كما يحتاج خفض التضخم على المدى
المتوسط الى تسريع التحول الهيكلي لخفض
عجز الحساب الجري وهذا له اهميه مصيريه
لتركيا بحسب هيئه الاحصاء الرسميه تراجع
معدل التضخم على اساس سنوي الى 39% هو
مؤشر ايجابي لكنه ما يزال بعيدا عن
المستهدف ويضغط على ظروف المواطن المعيشيه
يقول الخبراء ان تعزيز سعر صرف الليره
التركيه امام العملات الاجنبيه يستغرق
وقتا ويتطلب اجراءات على عده مستويات
اقتصاديه وماليه وهو التحدي الابرز امام
الحكومه الجديده ووزير ماليتها الذي يضع
الاستقرار النقدي وكبح جماح التضخم على
راس الاولويات فرح الزمان شوقي الجزيره
انقره